improvised explosive device
we're barely out of the icu when they
roll up camera scrolling fresh footage
[Music]
what to say wanted to show people how
much they care about vets
that's right they gave us nova implants
pre-med care
even the big cats from the board showed
up
then they packed up their cameras and
forgot all about you
yeah and get this those implants
we had to get them back replaced them
with these first gen pieces of garbage
they did a dirty yo took everything from
us tossed us like
like it's okay i understand
you a corporal tell me or i shoot
not a [ __ ] suit name's v regina sent
me
vegeta
tell her she can get [ __ ]
heard your interview on the way up
started broadcasting the moment you
showed up on the feed
it wasn't finished not like i wanted it
but at least people got the truth
there's a death warrant out for you but
you probably already knew that
uh yeah i could give a [ __ ] too but
regina wants to help you out
help me out she's the one who needs help
she was the best media i knew [ __ ] she
was my mentor
now sold right out
but i won't be bought not me
regina was your mentor not just mine
she was the best war reporter in night
city
then she turned fixer yep like i said
sold out
things used to be different the media's
word
[ __ ] meant something we tracked those
sons of [ __ ] every dirty move
but now you can prove halts in arasaka's
pocket
and nobody gives a flying turdfucker
so why do that veteran piece if we're
all so fresh out of [ __ ] to give
so that people start asking questions
start wondering
just like you now maybe that little
grain of discomfort will grow into
dissent who knows
i figure it's worth a try come on let's
go
you go the way of the gonk here won't
change your thing
running won't change anything either
i'll manage without your help
this all out of spite for regina you got
something to prove to her
you don't know jack
got a niche for the truth don't you if
you want to know who regina is now
what she really fights for just go and
see her
at the very least it'd mean a lot to her
max
[Music]
i'll talk to her but that's it that's
all i ask
okay just gotta download a few things
do what you gotta do
so
chauffeur what's next champagne black
market synth cigars
no time to waste let's go take care max
yeah you two
um
thanks for the help glad you got through
to that stubborn mule
looks like i'm up to bat with him now
gig closed
oh
you